in a country on any place on the planet
at any point in human history that is
more free
more generous more welcoming and more
respectful of the rights of all people
than the united states of america
so tomorrow we've got to vote for david
perdue and kelly lefler
and bubba mcdonald this election is
about the kind of country
that we are going to leave our children
and our grandchildren
we've got a we've got a turnout tomorrow
and we've got to leave them a country
that is free
that is proud that is strong where we
kneel before god
and where we stand for the flag
thank you very much god bless america
ladies and gentlemen congressman andrew
clyde to lead us in the prayer
hello north georgia it is great to see
you here tonight
thank you for coming out to support our
president and to support our senators
and to support bubba
a few weeks ago i was privileged to
speak at a rally for david and kelly
called
pray vote and stand as a u.s navy combat
veteran those
three words pray vote and stand are
fighting words to me
i trust they are for you too i fight
when i pray to our lord
god in heaven because he is the creator
of all
and all authority rests in his hands i
fight when i cast my ballot
for that is the way we fight in a
republic that is governed
by the people and for the people
to all the republicans in georgia
especially in georgia
14 right here and georgia 9 the
powerhouses of georgia
i need you to fight with me for our
state
and for our nation by going to the polls
tomorrow and voting
do not let it be said of you he didn't
vote then after you have voted
stand with us on january the 6th stand
with president trump
and help pres help us preserve liberty
the whole world is watching
so tomorrow let's fight and win make it
your priority to vote
for our two senators and for bubba
senator david perdue and kelly lefler
now please bow your heads with me
as we talk to the creator of the
universe our lord god almighty
heavenly father we come to you today
with thankful hearts and we fully
understand that all the blessings we
have in this country
come from your hand you ordained this
nation over 200
years ago and it was you who gave our
founding fathers great wisdom and
courage
as our nation was born fill us again
with that same wisdom and courage
to fight for the republic you have given
us
we are all sinners lord we have failed
you in many ways
yet you remain faithful to us
in your holy word you say if my people
will humble themselves and pray turn
from their wicked ways
then i will hear from heaven and will
forgive their sin
and heal their land father
we humble ourselves and earnestly pray
right now for your direct intervention
because
you can do everything that we cannot
and we are nothing without you
father you raise up governments and you
take them down
all power and authority rests in your
hands
tomorrow we ask that the voters of
georgia seek your wisdom
and guidance as they vote for you have
not given us
a spirit of fear but of love of power
and a sound mind the stakes have never
been higher lord
as the future of our country is on the
line
but you alone are god and america is in
your hands
we humbly ask your will be done
for your honor and glory please bless
president trump
senators purdue and senator loffler
and commissioner baba and all the other
republican leaders across our country
let them always guide america towards
freedom
towards liberty towards justice
and above all father towards you in the
precious name of jesus we ask
amen
ladies and gentlemen to lead us in the
pledge state senator steve
gooch
hello dalton whitfield county
hello north georgia
and hello american patriots
let's hear it ladies and gentlemen
please stand and remove your cover and
join me
as we honor our great flag in this great
country
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
united states of america
and to the republic for which it stands
one
ladies and gentlemen performing the
national anthem will martin
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light
what so probably we hail
at the twilight's last gleaming
who's brought stripes and bright stars
through the perilous fight
or the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly
streaming and
the rockets red glare
the bombs bursting in
air proof
through the night that
our flag was still there
oh say does that star
spangled
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen georgia public
service commissioner bubba mcdonald
hello georgia
i'm bubba
it's a great night to see all of you
here tonight how many have already voted
how many are gonna go vote tomorrow yeah
even better great you know it's
first let me get a couple of things out
of the way here
uh thank you for giving me the privilege
and the honor to serve
you on the georgia public service
commission and i humbly ask for your
vote again
for one more time i appreciate it i got
a little story i want to share with you
for a moment
a couple of weeks ago i had a former
commissioner of mine a friend
called me and said baba i'm 76 years of
age
and i've been black 76 years
but he said i want to send senator
leffler and senator to purdue
a check not much money but i want to
give them a check because
what they stand for and what it means to
this country
i just want to show my support in a mega
way
i said german if you'll do that send me
it to me i will personally put the check
in these songs hands he did i did and
they said thank you america that's what
happened
what we need to do now you know there
were
several percentages of libertarians that
voted
in the in the november election
we need to invite them to come in and
join us in this vote
we need to invite the independents that
vote independent to join in with the
republican move
and we need to invite thinking democrats
and you know there are some thinking
democrats out there
so we need to open our arms up and
invite
all of them in and join the force to
keep america
america that's what we need to do
now my opponent my opponent in this race
has his arms around the green new deal
that's all i need to say about that
except for this if that were to happen
save your candles keep your candles
you can do away with your kerosene lamps
because there won't be any kerosene
but and you won't be able to have
electricity well if you could afford it
you might have some
or the thermal gas because they're going
to stop fracking
but we're not going to let that happen
are we no we're not going to let it
happen
absolutely not so the you know the the
ball's in your court
the song georgia on my mind but america
has george on its mind right now
and we need to remember that and we need
to make sure
and we need to talk to everybody that
maybe not have voted yet
ask them for take them to the polls and
let's get them voted
because ladies and gentlemen this is
serious business
very serious and of course i'll be the
only bub
on the ballot and uh so
so anyway keep the enthusiasm up i'm
enthusiastic about it i've been with
secretary perdue and
commissioner gary black all over the
state last week and we find the
enthusiasm
and let's do it are we going to do it
usa usa
usa usa usa
thank you very much
ladies and gentlemen georgia state
representative vernon jones
oh
oh
hello america
hello georgia
i'm remindful of my mother she said son
when you're talking think about
something
as you speak think about a woman's skirt
my mama said this now
you want to keep it short
you want to keep it interesting
and boy you want to cover the best parts
don't blame me that's what my mama said
now
i'm honored to be here tonight
with such patriots and great americans
you have revealed to me that you're
determined
to move on anyhow
you know what's interesting
that far left think they can take this
election
but we're here tonight to send him a
strong message
you will not steal the vote no more in
georgia
we are fired up and we're not taking no
more
our leader donald trump is coming here
tonight
and if i'm in a foxhole and we are in a
foxhole we're in the fighter our lives
when you're in a foxhole you want donald
trump in the foxhole with you
because donald trump will fight for you
he'll fight his last of his last breath
because of what he believed in standing
up for you and standing for me
and putting america first
tonight is crucial
y'all know i'm a lifelong democrat
but i'm not here to save the democratic
party
i'm here to save the democratic republic
i love this country
all the men and women who served in the
military and all the first responders
i want you to know we got your back
let me tell you what's at stake if you
don't go and vote
for kelly leffler loffler or david
perdue
here's what's at stake your first
amendment rights your freedom of
expression
secondly we have to be defenders of the
second amendment and they want to take
our guns away
they embrace socialism communism
and marxism if you think that works
then you should move to venezuela
when you start to talk about defunding
the police
who the hell you call when you dial
9-1-1 and you want to show up at your
door
and you want to take away
funding from them they need more funding
for more training
and more education they're talking about
sending a social worker to answer
a 9-1-1 call
who in the hell is going to protect the
social worker
that's what the left stands for and
that's what's at stake
school choice
democratic policies have kept our
children and failed in schools for years
let the parent determine where they
should send their child to school
and not the damn government
many children are trapped in schools
right now and failing schools because of
their zip code
that's a crime shame what side of the
street they live on
paris knows what's best for their
children
democrats do not want us to have school
choice because they're so tied into
the unions
this is america we deserve better
let me tell you what else is at stake
i was listening today
when nancy post closing
ice cream nancy pelosi
with that high-end refrigerator
i can tell you that wasn't a freezer
there
but i'm looking at they're changing the
rules
on the house floor
no longer can a member say man or woman
father or mother sister
or brother you have to call each other a
member
remember this remember that let me tell
you what's going to happen there
you're going to see them pass
legislation
that when your sibling you go to school
with your sister your brother and you
pass him in the hallway
you cannot say hello brother hello
sister you got to say hello
sibling
they're about to erase father mother
from our vocabulary
you can't even say father mother now
they want you to say parent
this is what the left is pushing i'm
telling you
the liberals have hijacked so many
including the african-american community
to carry out their liberal agenda they
didn't give a damn about black people
this is what the left is doing
i implore you right now and i know
you're bitter
i know you're disturbed and i know
you're discouraged about
what happened in november i am too i'm
frustrated too
i'm mad as hell too but i'm not gonna
let them
left let the left get away this time
we're going out in record numbers
and we're gonna send us off and we're
gonna send warlord
back home
we're georgians we have traditional
values
we believe in hard work the left
they want to give everything away for
free
my mother told me a long time ago son
there's no free lunches
they want to raise taxes on us
to get us out of this deficit
but on the other hand they want to close
businesses down
keep people from working so they can pay
their fair share
and that's how we grow this economy not
through raising people's taxes
and that's what they're going to do and
if we don't see a nancy pelosi i mean we
don't see her back home
and elect david perdue and kelly loffler
let me tell you what's going to happen
they are going to pick off some of those
rhinos
watch what happens they're going to cave
in we have to send a strong message
georgia the world is looking at you
we're not just fighting for georgia
we're fighting for the entire union
this country
we cannot allow what they're trying to
do
to you and me and my family your small
business
and your independent rights to your
constitutional rights your choice your
freedom this is about freedom
they are literally raising us off the
face of the earth
i'm telling you and if you have freedom
in america where can you go for freedom
now i'm looking at every red-blooded
georgian here tonight and those from
surrounding states
this race is going to be lost or won
tomorrow
that's what i want to hear it's going to
be one and you know it's going to be one
because we're going to send so many
votes they can't out fraud us
there's no way they can
now these rallies are important and i
feel your energy here tonight but we
have to take this across all 159
counties
of this state you got to call everybody
you know
and tell them to get out because
democrats they've gotten their early
voters in
but republicans are relying on you to
vote on election day
so if you haven't vote you get out there
and you vote like you're crazy
because if they win if the left win you
are going to be crazy
and i'm serious about it think about
your children's future at stake here
now i've taken a lot of crap from the
democratic party
i got more arrows in my back than i can
count
but i'm not gonna back down from no damn
body
[Applause]
y'all know about it you heard the
stories
and if i could stand and still fight i
know you can
we have to this is our time
we're going to show those liberals we're
going to show the left
we're going to show big tech we're going
to show a little tech
we're going to show cnn we're going to
show msnbc
rachael mata anderson cooper and the
whole damn crew
that we are coming and we're bringing
hell with us
i love this country
but this is one time you can say i'm an
angry black man
i am an angry black man tonight because
i love this country so much when i see
it being taken away from us
when i see our traditional family values
are being taken from us when i see they
want to take away our guns
they want to take away our right to
choose
and to exercise our freedom of
expression and
when i think about what the left wants
to do
they want to attack you and me because
of our political ideology and our
political
affiliation you want to scratch my car
because i have a trump bumper sticker on
it
i can't work because i'm afraid of being
fired because i say i'm a trump
supporter
i can't do a damn thing because the left
want to take your life
away from you that's what's happening
there should be a hate crime and i'm
calling the governor right now
and the entire georgia general assembly
to make it a hate crime
to attack someone because of their party
affiliation
to attack someone
because their political ideology and to
attack someone from wearing the damn mag
ahead
that's my right to where i'm at if i
want to wear a maca hat
america i coined the phrase
i heard the president used it the other
day that's when i knew i arrived no not
phil laverne i love phil de verne
hold the line hold the line america
hold the line america hold the line
america
hold the line america hold a line
hold a line hold a line for georgia
we mean business
love you america and there's nothing you
can do about it peace out
ladies and gentlemen please welcome
kimberly guilfoyle
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
well hello good evening georgia how you
feeling tonight
[Applause]
georgia where my soldiers at
[Applause]
georgia is trump country
is it not
[Applause]
who is the greatest american president
in the united states
[Applause]
are we going to keep georgia red
let's get after it
who's gonna show up and vote tomorrow
[Applause]
as vernon said everything is on the line
and we
will hold the line it is up to the great
fearless patriotic state of georgia to
save
this country will you deliver for
america
[Applause]
i think we need to keep trump in the
white house and we need to hold the
senate
are you in
we will stand for our liberties for our
freedoms for the founding fathers that
fought to protect and preserve
for the american military for the
veterans to put it all on the line
we will show up tomorrow in the great
fearless
state of georgia and deliver and show
this country what it means to be a
patriotic american
[Applause]
let's deliver the summit red
for the republicans for this country for
the president of the united states with
david perdue
and kelly lafleur what do you say
georgia what do you say
georgia let's go let's win
let's deliver let's show them who's boss
this is our country we don't allow
people to steal
elections or the white house or the
presidency
they will not push through us
we will hold the line you like that
in this country we need fearless
patriots that will stand with our
incredible president
who has delivered on the promise and the
freedoms of america
with america first policies fighting for
what we believe in because he has fought
for every single one of you
and so will kelly lefler and david
perdue
[Applause]
[Music]
these three incredible americans believe
that you have the common sense
the judgment the hard work to provide
for
your families to decide what you do with
your money
because they believe that you have more
common sense than the swamp in dc
they want you to decide how to educate
your
children they want you to go to your
house of worship to your
church to pray and that's when we take a
knee and we will not take a need of
socialism or communism in this country
under left floor purdue and trump
america
will never be a socialist country
[Music]
we stand for our freedoms we stand for
religion
we stand for the second amendment and
our first
amendment freedoms for who we believe in
who we fight for teach your children
your families a lesson that we are
unafraid that we are proud that we
love this country and we will not let
other countries
influence this country we stand in
leadership
we stand behind our president and we
stand
behind fearless senators in this country
that honor you and your family do we
love it
[Applause]
you like lower taxes
[Music]
same do you like deciding what you do
with your money and how you spend it
do you like your children going to
school
open schools instead of open borders
do you like national security a strong
and fearless military in this country
that leads by example
and excellence donald trump
has rebuilt the promise of america and
the american dream
i stand in front of you as a proud and
fearless first-generation american
my father born in ireland working in
blacksmith shop since he was 13 years of
age
fighting to provide for his family and
his five younger brothers and sisters
he got the chance to come to this
country and serve proudly in the united
states military serving in the army
to give back to the country that have
blessed him with so much
and my mother working as a special
education teacher believing and loving
children
and honoring the promise in the future
of this incredible country
where all of us have the equality of
opportunity
and we will determine the results for
our life by
hard work and perseverance and faith and
belief
in god
donald trump has put america back to
work and we have
two incredible fearless individuals and
kelly leffler and david perdue that want
to honor
you and your family that want to earn
your vote tomorrow will you show up
george on vote
the whole world is watching
the whole world and your incredible
president
is coming here tonight to honor you in
the great state of georgia
because georgia is setting the example
for this country and holding the line
and will deliver the future for this
country
history will look back and say it was
the people of the great state of georgia
that never gave up
and that's why we're back here again and
i have to tell you i have the great
honor and pride
to work every single day with an
incredible maverick who loves his father
who
fights and believes in this country and
that's donald trump
jr the son of the president of the
united states
and he loves georgia let's give him a
round
of applause of welcome let's fight for
this country
god bless you georgia vote purdue
vote lefleur let's bring home the
victory tomorrow
hold the senate and let's hold the white
house give it up for don jr
[Music]
[Music]
here i come back
[Music]
[Music]
hello georgia
[Applause]
if i was joe biden i'd say hello alaska
no one would even bat an eye right you
saw last week he couldn't get
ossoff's name right he said something
totally different because
he doesn't even know where he is but but
he definitely
got a lot more votes than barack obama
did in oa right we all believed that
right
no one's that stupid
no one's that stupid folks
but that's why we can do hunter too if
you want
i do i mean in all fairness guys i take
that one a little personally because i
look at sort of what they did to me
and to my family for four years
fake russia hoaxes fake russia collusion
didn't stop them from running with it
frankly they're still running with it as
though it was real
but when someone's actually taking money
from the chinese communist party
no one has a problem with it i always
ask if it was donald jr
what do you think would happen vernon
what do you think would happen
jail at best i mean they did say
they accused me of committing treason a
crime punishable by death minor details
you know a little crime that they hang
people for
or firing squad but but when someone's
actually doing it
no problem when someone's taking money
from russian oligarchs with ties to
putin
as long as you're a democrat it's okay
i agree and that's why we have to fight
to prevent that double standard from
being executed
it's why we have to be in the game
[Applause]
you the people of georgia
can decide what we the people
can do to a democrat
administration and to democrats by
winning the united states senate and
holding that line regardless of what
happens
you can do what they tried to do to my
father for the last
four years you can put the people in
there that will block
their radical agenda
their agenda that would lock down your
business
that will lock down your schools that
has locked down your
churches you can
cast the vote for logic
for reason for common sense
all of those things that aren't so
common anymore
in the democrat mindset and while we're
thank you sir i appreciate that but
let's focus on tomorrow and then january
[Applause]
i love you too
and i love you too sir it's okay you
know it's
well guys guess what you can do that
you can be a part of that by putting
fighters in there and
david perdue senator he's up tomorrow
he was i believe the second senator i'd
say the first but
he was at least the top two senators in
16 that came out
for donald trump do me a favor
go fight for him tomorrow
[Applause]
kelly lafleur has fought for donald
trump and will continue to fight for
donald trump
fight for her tomorrow
[Applause]
again you guys can decide now i hear
this all the time and this is like one
of the dumbest things ever
you know it's dumb when the media
latches on to it to try to make it so
because you know they're trying to do
the opposite of what would be good for
you
for us and for america right that's
their thing
they push the chinese communist
propaganda talking points
because they want that money they don't
care so much about america
so what you guys got to do is you got to
get out there and fight because i see
some of these
supposed republicans out there saying oh
you know i don't like the way the game
is played
i'm going to take my ball and go home
and we shouldn't go vote
i go what it is the dumbest
statement made in the history
of politics and that's saying something
because there's been a lot of
democrat administrations
so that is a serious statement but i
mean it
guys when you're at a disadvantage you
don't take your ball and go home
you get out there and you fight harder
[Applause]
you think no think about it right you
guys like trump
yeah i think you like trump
what did donald trump do back in 2016
and 2015 when they said i believe we had
it was
something like zero percent chance of
winning
right we had a zero percent chance of
winning the primary
we then had a zero percent chance of
winning the general
everyone counted us out what did he do
he went and he fought
like an animal okay he wasn't gonna take
their put-downs he wasn't gonna take
them laughing at him and stop
he was gonna fight because this country
is worth fighting for
our freedoms are worth fighting for
our children are worth fighting for and
guys
as the father of five young kids
yeah i know how that happens now i got a
new hobby i got into politics
almost as brutal
but as a father of five young kids
i want them to recognize the america
that i know and love when they're my age
and the way we're going right now guys
they're not going to
you saw i believe it was yesterday they
introduced
the start of the 117th congress
and they ended the prayer with amen
and a woman
think about this amen
and a woman this is it tells you
everything you need to know about the
democrat party
i mean these people are freaking morons
[Applause]
i mean think no you can never be woke
enough to appease these people
you can't do it like you can't try
they're not even a parody of themselves
at this point
it's insane amen is not a gendered
term okay if i go to a restaurant and i
ask to see what's on the
warm menu
they would look at me like i'm a [ __ ]
and they would be right
okay it's not a gendered term and by the
way
if it was who cares what are we three
but the start of the 117th congress
ended with amen as it should
a little latin word that means so be it
whatever you know it's only been used
for a couple thousand years no big deal
but because it had men in there
somewhere even though it had nothing to
do with men
they had to also include the women now i
like including women
right kimberly where's kimberly
if i don't include kimberly i'd be in
big trouble
you don't want the puerto rican pitbull
on you trust me
right baby am i covered
we good did kimberly do a good job
no one works harder than kim i promise
you but she's fighting for what we all
believe in folks that's what makes it
easy
i don't do this for a living amazingly
enough unlike hunter biden i was
actually an international business
person before politics
not because of politics
but when i see what's going on when i
see the nonsense that they're throwing
at us
when i see that georgia has two people
running for the united states senate
that would both be
the most radical senators in the senate
the most radical leftist socialist
commiemasters you could imagine
coming from the state of georgia that
worries me
one was on china's payroll
john assaf the other the others
i mean did you see that video of his
wife
brett's telling the cop no he's a
wonderful actor he's a terrible person
he beat like
i mean imagine that warnock was a
conservative
and there's a video of his wife accusing
him of
beating her running her over with a car
or something like that it's insane right
imagine that was a republican
he wouldn't be able to leave his house
he wouldn't be able to get a job
he certainly wouldn't be running for the
united states senate in georgia
but because the media and their leftist
agenda
they give him a total pass like they
give joe biden and like they've given
all democrats
like they gave nancy pelosi who's more
than happy to lock you down with her
rules
that she doesn't have to abide by
kobet is very serious but it's not
seriously enough to not force you to go
to washington to vote for nancy
pelosi kova is very serious you better
not open up your business
except to give her a haircut
and then when someone calls her out
on her flagrant hypocrisy
rather than owning it because she knows
she doesn't have to own
her mistakes her glaring errors she
doesn't have to own them because she
knows the media will cover
rather than owning it it
was a setup holy [ __ ]
it was a setup
i mean in all fairness she's number
three in line to the nuclear codes
i don't want someone who's number three
in line to the nuclear codes
being set up by her hair salon
[Music]
if you're being set up by your hair
salon how you gonna do against
iran how are you going to do against
russia
how about china we must say that with
the pop
the correct vernacular china
china is so thrilled that the media is
pushing for joe biden to win this thing
because they know
they got it imagine the stuff that we've
seen about hunter you know all those
things that they won't cover in the
media even though no one's actually
denying that it's all accurate
imagine how much more they have
imagine imagine how much more their spy
agencies have
that our media you know one person dug
for about three minutes and they found
some pretty substantial stuff
imagine what the chinese government has
done to make sure they can exert control
over america which is what they've
wanted
for years trust me when china sees
congress opening up with a prayer that
says amen and a woman
they are laughing their asses off
and if i was them i would be too
we should be crying because it's
pathetic
but guys as i've said the united states
senate
could be the last line of defense
and it's up to you all you got to do is
show up but you can't listen to the
[ __ ] saying
we don't want to participate you got to
go work harder like donald trump did
when faced with adversity when faced
with
what everyone said was insurmountable
obstacles he went out there and he
fought
harder and we need you to do that for
the next 24 hours
we need you getting out there and voting
yourselves we need you calling your
friends
we need you texting them don't let
georgia
be the starting point for the radical
left in the united states senate
because that's who they are running
it's up to you georgia listen
what do i know i'm just the guy from new
york city
but i do like my guns i think you do too
i like them a lot
that's on the line
your religious freedoms that's on the
line everything is on the line because
as they've said
everything is on the table you heard
chuck schumer right
first we get georgia then we change
america
they're not even hiding from the radical
agenda anymore there is no such thing
as a moderate democrat that party is
long gone
this party this democrat party
is a marxist socialist party it's a
communist party
you notice the difference between the
red states and the blue states and how
they've handled lockdowns
at this point it seems like the blue
states they don't even care if they put
you out of business
it's the first time in american history
where you get into more trouble
for opening your business than you do
for burning down someone else's
we can't allow that to happen
we need to fight
it's up to you guys
it's up to you all right
you're gonna get out there and fight
imagine imagine what would happen to you
if you chanted usa at a democrat rally
it'd be ugly i mean it's sort of nice
you had the prayer you had the pledge
starts yeah i mean amazing
they wouldn't even think of doing these
things anymore you know to them
that would be some sort of form of
oppression i guess i
you know you saw that right they two
weeks ago they tried canceling helen
keller
no you saw that right helen keller
who was born in 1880 was blind
and deaf became an activist they
cancelled her because
she was white privileged
true story i mean
a comedic writer could not come up with
things that are
dumber or funnier than today's democrat
party platform
so again you guys have a choice
you can show up tomorrow and vote you
can put up that last line of defense
you can put david perdue and kelly
lefler
back in the senate so they can fight for
my father
so they can fight for his agenda which
they all
want to reverse on the democrat side
right they want to raise your taxes
they want to close your schools they
want to get rid of energy
they want your taxpayer dollars going
for free health care for
illegals not for yourself you have to
pay for that too but for illegals
they're not looking out for america and
they're not looking out for americans
just look at their actions they speak
for themselves guys
but we need to wake up we need to be
engaged we need to stay engaged and we
need to fight
like donald trump fights if we do that
if we do that we win
and we can save our country and we can
use the time to fight for more people
who will actually fight
more people who will actually engage not
like the mitt romney paul ryans of the
world but
you know yeah
not like them but we can fight
for guys who will fight for what we
believe in for women who will fight for
what we believe in
to preserve all of the things that made
america the greatest nation
in the world
[Applause]
but if you don't get out there tomorrow
guys
you may never get that chance you
squander that opportunity
the democrats they've said it they're
going to pack the courts
they're going to give d.c and puerto
rico statehood that's four permanent
democrat senators
and it's over folks they know it
like i said they want you to be dejected
they want you to be upset they want you
to take your ball
and go home that's been their dream for
decades
they want you broken and beaten so they
can push their nonsense through
do not allow it to happen have the
resolve that donald trump had
and you can get the results that donald
trump got right think about it
look at all he's accomplished with zero
help from the democrats
he grew the strongest economy rebuilt
our military held our enemies
accountable put pressure
i mean the things that his
accomplishments go on and on
he actually got things done because he
was willing to take on washington but if
you take your ball and go home
you'll never have that opportunity again
once you lose those rights
you don't get them back just look at
what the democratic governors have done
in those states they were really quick
to take your freedoms not so quick to
want to give them back
don't let it get there guys okay so
georgia
you have a mission for the next 24 hours
let's get out there
let's kick some ass let's win and let's
send kelly leveler and david purdue back
to the united states senate
thank you georgia
make no mistake today we're in an
ideological war for the future of our
republic
this is about our children and our
children's children
all eyes are on georgia as we head into
the january what happens in georgia
is going to determine the future of the
united states oh
georgia the road leads back to you
the battle lines have been drawn it's
freedom versus socialism
state streets or defunding beliefs
jobs versus the mod it's your choice
and your freedom against cancel culture
and blacklist
the georgia way or their way
political outsiders taking on a radical
and a pretender with the future of the
free world
at stake together we are going to stop
socialism in its tracks we win georgia
we save
america join us and together we will
hold the line
they said it couldn't be done if the
election were held today
i'd be surprised if republicans held on
to the senate you're going to end up
with
a democratic president the democratic
senate they're just racist like
susan collins we're just like they're
probably toast control of the senate
is absolutely in play they doubted us
every step of the way
your dream here is get by and present
and take back the senate
when we take back the senate and have
the majority we will have a lot to do
there's not a path to 12 for the
democrats but there is one
to eight or nine predictions of a blue
wave well they did not seem to pan out
the election night was a good
night for republican democrats went into
yesterday's election expecting to take
control of the u.s senate that is not
going to happen
november 3rd was just the start all
eyes are on george as we head into the
january run-off
the direction of the country is
literally on the ballot in georgia
georgia is a battle for the soul of
america
between two political outsiders
and two of the most radical democrats
you'll ever see we've called our police
officers
gangsters thugs bullies and a threat to
our children
what they want is total control but we
stand at a moment in history right now
the eyes of america are on georgia
they're on you
we don't vote we won't just lose we will
lose the country
and the eyes of the nation are on us
georgia an angry mob
is at the gate but republicans have the
watch
and we've come too far to turn back now
this is about saving america we win
georgia
we save america on january 5th
we must hold the line
[Music]
i've been telling my dreams to the
scarecrow
about the places that i'd like to see
i say friend do you think i'll ever get
there
oh but he just stands there smiling back
at me
so i can't
[Music]
is
[Music]
open your eyes
look up to the skies
[Music]
doesn't really fun
[Music]
life had just begun
[Music]
[Music]
carry really bad
[Music]
is
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
galileo
[Music]
[Music]
will you let me go
put oh for me
do you think you can love me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
nothing really matters
nothing really matters
to me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
hit me
but with the tax man
[Music]
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
there is
[Music]
i
[Music]
my
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
tell your children
in the house
[Music]
[Music]
and
is
[Music]
and it's me
i wonder
[Music]
me
[Music]
she was more like a movie
what young girls
[Music]
[Music]
just remember to always say twice
don't dance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
she
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
cheese
[Music]
[Music]
it's nine o'clock on a saturday
a regular crowd shuffles in
there's an old man sitting next to me
making love to his tonic engine
he says can you play me a memory i'm not
really sure
how it goes but it's sad and it's sweet
and i
knew it complete when i was
[Music]
sing us a song the other piano
[Music]
you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
now john at the bar is a friend of mine
he gets me my drinks for free
and he's quick with a joke how to light
up your smoke
but there's some place that he'd rather
[Music]
as a smile ran away from his face
well i'm sure that i could be a movie
star
if i could get out of this
[Music]
and he's talking with david who's still
in the navy
and probably will be
and the waitress is practicing politics
as the businessmen slowly get stoned
yes they're sharing a drink they call
loveliness
but it's better than drinking alone
[Music]
sing us the song you're the piano man
sing us a song tonight
well we're all in the mood for a melody
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
it's a pretty good crowd for a saturday
and the manager gives me a smile
cause he knows that it's me they've been
coming to see
to forget about life for a
[Music]
like while carnival and the microphone
smells like a beer
and they sit at the bar and put bread in
my
jar and say man what are you doing here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and you've got us feeling all right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ground control to major tom
ground control to major tongue
take your protein pills and put your
helmet on
ground control tomato tunnels
seven six commencing
countdown engines
mission and make god's love with you
[Music]
this is
[Music]
now it's time to leave
[Music]
i'm stepping through the door
[Music]
and the stars look very different
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
tell my wife very much
[Music]
can you hear me
[Music]
[Music]
is
i can do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
to too young
[Music]
me
[Music]
future lies
[Music]
[Music]
man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hello dalton bonnie and i really hate
that we can't be there with you and
president trump tonight
believe me folks this election tomorrow
could not be more critical
the very future of our republic is at
stake
tomorrow is the last chance we will have
to save all that president trump has
accomplished and to hold the line
against this radical socialist agenda of
the democrats
as the original outsider i was one of
only two
u.s senators to endorse then candidate
donald trump in early 2016.
i fought to get him elected and i fought
alongside of him
to turn around the american economy to
rebuild our military
to protect our borders to remake our
federal judiciary
and to bring a vaccine to us in less
than a year
i'm still fighting for him today
fighting to get a fair accounting here
in georgia
for weeks now i have been calling to
object to georgia electors in the u.s
senate on wednesday january the 6th
president trump has fought for us and
we're fighting for him in a fair and
accurate election
if you're as mad as i am about november
then rise up with us and fight
fight by doing the only thing you can do
right now and that is to vote tomorrow
if we don't all get out and vote
tomorrow everything president trump has
done to make america great again
is gone chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
want to change america forever
they want total control and will destroy
jobs and our economy with higher taxes
and more regulations they want to allow
illegal immigrants to vote
to defund our police to eliminate
private health insurance
and to pack our supreme court my
opponent
and kelly's opponent will be nothing but
rubber stamps for chuck schumer
in this radical socialist agenda only
you can stop them
the eyes of america are on us please
vote and get everyone you know to vote
we won't get a second chance
the people of georgia will determine if
our children in america
will live on an oppressive socialist
government or continue to enjoy the
freedom
that we all cherish so deeply simply put
we win georgia we save america
thank you god bless you and god bless
the united states of america
[Music]
you're always
i
you really don't remember
[Music]
is
dalton tower dalton tower this marine
one
be advised on final approach
[Music]
get
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hear me
[Music]
i've done my sentence
but committed no crime
and bad mistakes
i've met a few
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we
[Music]
is
[Music]
i've taken my
[Music]
you brought me fame and fortune at
everything that goes
i thank you all but it's been no better
[Music]
i consider it a challenge
[Music]
my
[Music]
the
friends
[Music]
we are
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
me
me
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
in the morning
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the united states
donald j trump
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time
[Music]
[Music]
god
[Music]
who
[Music]
next to you and defend her still
love this today god
i want to thank you very much hello
georgia by the way
there's no way we lost georgia there's
no way
that was a rigged election but we're
still fighting it and you'll see what's
going to happen we'll talk about it and
uh i just want to thank you this is some
crowd you know biden was here today also
they had 14 people in three cars
no there was no way and i just want to
thank you
you know i've had two elections i won
both of them it's amazing
and
and i actually did much better on the
second one
it's great to be back in this incredible
state the home of hard-working patriots
who believe in god
family and country
tomorrow each of you is going to vote in
one of the most important runoff
elections in the history of our country
but frankly forget about runoff one of
the most important
elections really it's really not runoff
it's elections because
uh it's a biggie our country is
depending on you the whole world is
watching the people of georgia tomorrow
and you got to swamp them because
everything's so crooked around i mean
not
and not here they were saying oh he's
complaining about georgie no no i'm
complaining about eight different states
uh and i think we're going to win them
all you're going to get
everyone you know you're going to show
up at the polls in record numbers you
got to swamp them and together we're
going to defeat
the democratic streamers and deliver and
thundering
victory to david perdue and where's
david david david he we love our david i
know david so well he's respected
and loved by everyone and someone that
has really been a star
in washington kelly leffler where is
kelly
[Applause]
where is our kelly what a job you've
done
thank you i will tell you about kelly
[Applause]
kelly fights for me david fights for me
that i can tell you
and i will also say you know the
republicans you have to understand for
the people that don't fight not for me
fighting for us
because we have a lot of corrupt things
that happen
when they don't fight one thing i've
learned about republicans they have
some difficulties but you know a
difficulty that they don't have
they never forget they never forget and
people are going to find that out
because
uh we have to go and we have to go all
the way and that's what's happening and
you watch what happens over the next
couple of weeks you watch what's going
to come out watch what's going to be
revealed
you watch
and i have to tell you that the stakes
of this election
could not be higher you vote tomorrow
you want to go out tomorrow people want
to go out they don't want to do the
the ballot thing they don't want to do
it unless it's the other side in which
case they just print them out
they don't want to do it they want to go
and vote and make sure your vote is
counted make sure they don't let you say
i'm sorry somebody else has already
voted for you
your vote tomorrow will decide which
party controls the united states senate
the radical democrats are trying to
capture georgia's senate seats
so they can wield unchecked unrestrained
absolute power over
every aspect of your lives
[Music]
if the liberal democrats take the senate
of the white house
and they're not taking this white house
we're gonna fight like hell i'll tell
you right now
you know i was telling kelly before
you can lose and that's acceptable you
lose you lose you go and you
go wherever you're going and you go and
say maybe i'll do it again sometime or
maybe i won't or i'll get back to life
but when you win in a landslide and they
steal
it and it's rigged it's not acceptable
not acceptable then you have a
a country that would be run if these two
don't win
and if we don't take the presidency you
have a country that would be run by
schumer pelosi and biden
[Applause]
the people of georgia will be at the
mercy of the left-wing socialists
communists
marxist and that's where it's going you
know we don't like to use the
word communist how about the press look
at them are back there look at all of
them
how about the press it's a lot of press
oh boy that's a lot of press but you
know
they've gone silent now they have a new
thing they used to fight me left right
i'd go they'd go you know you'd fight
i'd win that but who knows who wins
but people would hear now they don't
want to talk about it unless they can
say
something bad about you they don't want
to talk about it
so if we talk about certain subjects
that you've been watching over the last
six months
all of a sudden they were getting
clobbered so they went
stone cold silent big tech
the fake news media they go silent
anymore they don't talk about it
and that is the beginning of communism
that's exactly what happened
because i think they hate our country
and they despise
georgia values and i think a lot of you
despise them as you know
there's nothing the radical democrats
will not do
to get power that they so desperately
crave even the outright
stealing of elections like they're
trying to do
with us we're not going to let it happen
over the past
and i hope mike pence comes through for
us i have to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
now mike is a great guy he said he's a
he's a wonderful man and a smart man and
a man that i like a lot but he's gonna
have a lot to say about it and he you
know one thing with him
you're gonna get straight shots he's
gonna call it straight
over the past few weeks we've
demonstrated that we won the election in
a landslide almost
75 million people voted for me
the most of any incumbent president in
the history of our country
we won over 11 million close to 12
million more votes in 2016 one of the
largest actually the single largest
increase in the history of our country
no person that won
went to a second term or went through an
election
where he got nearly 12 million votes
no it never happened before never
happened before
we made historic gains among
african-americans hispanic americans
asian-americans and we won the largest
share of non-white vote
of any republican president in 60 years
we also won 18 out of 19 bellwether
counties now when you win
just a few bellwether counties you
always win the election
we won 18 out of 19 that's a record and
they said we didn't win
we won 25 of 26
toss-up house races and i think we have
one that we're waiting for right did you
see the one in
hello mike how are you mike did you see
the one in
new york where claudia good woman they
keep
finding votes they keep finding about
she's up by 18. oh we just found 19
votes
that's uh same kind of stuff democrats
were projected to gain
15 house seats and instead and
kevin mccarthy gives us the credit good
man
very good man my coattails we swept
our republican house candidates to
victory we have a couple of great ones
with us tonight
and the democrats lost 14 seats it was
supposed to be the other way around
[Applause]
and when that happens no president loses
unless they play games that you don't
lose they play games the fact is
we won the presidential election we won
it big
and we're going to win tomorrow we're
going to win it really big we have to
people have no idea how important that
is tonight our mission here in georgia
is to make sure the radical left cannot
rob you of your voice
and your votes in washington you can't
lose these two people
and i really know them well they're the
most respected people they're great
people
and they really do have a voice and they
love their state and they love their
country the democrats are trying to
steal the white house
you cannot let them you just can't let
them
steal the u.s senate you can't let it
happen
you can't let it happen david and kelly
are running against the most extreme
liberal candidates in the history of
your state
probably in the history of our country
john ossoff
and rafael warnock
[Applause]
well you know i beat ossoff once
running against a very fine woman karen
who you know
and uh he was at 57 and i got involved
we drove him down to 49 and then he
ended up in runoff
and she ended up winning now i have to
beat him a second time and this is going
to be
hopefully easy because when you know
what
he stands for when you know what warnock
stands for
it really should be easy cast deciding
votes to rubber stamp
the agenda of aoc and bernie
sanders crazy burning stacey abrams
what's with his stacey abrams
[Applause]
you know your governor your governor and
your secretary
of state they're petrified of stacey
abrams
what's that all about did you see this
consent decree they signed
with signature verification you can
forget about it
what they have done to your state i
think most people have no idea what
they've done to your state
that consent decree of these two people
i don't know they say they're they say
they're republicans i really don't think
they are they can't be
like if we want to have a special
session because your legislature's
excellent they want to have us
why wouldn't they let us have a special
session if they want to check
signatures in fulton county not in cobb
county we didn't ask for cop county
they said we'll do cop first and then
we'll do fulton they do cop
then they never get the phone why
wouldn't they do that
why wouldn't they do that that's a
positive thing
anyway the democrats want to turn
america i'll be here in about a year and
a half campaigning against your governor
i guarantee you
[Applause]
i shouldn't say this i shouldn't say
this because
i just don't want you to tell anybody
outside of this room other than the
millions of people
no but you know i endorsed him he was in
last place
and i endorsed him he went to first
place very like immediately and then he
won the
primary and then i gave him a couple of
rallies which i don't like doing for
other people i was telling him i don't
do rallies for other people i do them
for me right
not that easy crowd like this they say
over 25 000 people
over what over a couple of days notice
and is everybody glad you're here right
i think so
there is no place like a trump rally but
you know what this is a kelly rally and
a david rally
and i wouldn't do it unless i loved him
both i wouldn't do it
but i'm going to be here in a year and a
half and i'm going to be campaigning
against your governor and your crazy
secretary of state that i can tell you
and you have great candidates they want
to turn
the democrats to america into venezuela
with no jobs no prosperity no rights no
freedom
no future for you and your family
here is exactly what the radical left
will do if they win
this runoff election which we can't let
them do tomorrow tomorrow's a big day i
guess we have to get
over a million votes tomorrow right
kelly over a million
all right that's a lot of votes kelly
but we'll do it
and the one thing i know if they win
i'll get no credit
and if they lose they're going to blame
trump these people
and kelly won't let that happen please
win tomorrow
you're going to win so big it's going to
be great story
it's a great story a very important
story for our country long beyond
georgia for our country it's such a big
story
they'll massively raise your taxes on
the middle class to pay for socialism
the u.s military
which we rebuilt we've totally rebuilt
the us military much of it coming right
out of
georgia
[Music]
we built it right out of georgia a lot
of it you have incredible
contractors in georgia military
contractors and they got plenty of our
money
spent 2.5 trillion dollars when i took
over the military it was absolutely a
mess it was
depleted now it's the opposite of
depleted the u.s military will
be gutted a military families across the
street
and all over the state will be betrayed
their benefits and opportunities will be
slashed
fort benning fort gordon and other
georgia military
institutions will be the first on the
chopping block
and by the way they'll be forced to
change the names of the bases
where generations of american patriots
trained to win two world wars i don't
know
fort benning let's see give me a couple
of names i could give you some
i don't want to give them the credit but
you'll name them you'll name them after
other people for trump yeah how about
that i like that
yeah let's change today let's change it
kelly
let's change it if they name it trump
let's change it now now they're going to
go back and say
he wants to have fort benning change to
trump
watch they'll say he's asking he's
begging for fort benning to be changed
no no i don't want that the democrats
will surrender the entire u.s
manufacturing industry to
china
[Applause]
you notice they never criticized china
right they never could
it's russia russia russia i saw it today
again russia russia oh russia
here we go that was another great scam
i've been involved in the two greatest
scams in american history
the russian hopes and now they are
trying to steal an election from us
and we won not by a little bit we won in
numbers like nobody's seen before
if ossoff and warnock are elected they
will immediately thrill and
you know what's going to happen they'll
throw open
american borders and allow tens of
millions of illegal
immigrants to pour into our country from
every corner of the globe
your schools your hospitals and your
communities will be overwhelmed
and the wall the wall the wall remember
we'll build a wall we're gonna build the
wall
and that's right mexico is paying for
the wall if i were here there would be
because we were going to charge him a
nice fee right at the entry points
and uh they were paying for the wall
they paid for 28
000 troops along the wall and along the
border which we don't need so much
anymore
but we built almost 500 miles of wall
and they want to rip down the wall they
want to rip down that's why the numbers
have been so great but now everyone's
coming back
up because they think this guy's going
to win and if he wins it's going to be
everything that they could dream for
dream up and you know we want to help
other people but we can't afford to do
it
we can't afford to do it so they're
coming up now the caravans remember the
caravans the caravans are starting to
form here they come
but uh let's uh let's keep this thing
going we have great support
in congress we have good support in the
senate i wouldn't say great
could be better but people will remember
the people that don't support us
if they win this race democrats will
implement nationwide catch and release
you know what that is you catch a
criminal
and you take his name you say you're
released into our country
i ended it you're released come back in
four years
we're going to take you to court so far
nobody's ever shown up i mean literally
they almost don't show up and turn our
that's when i had the big debate with
biden they come back for court i said no
they don't
i turned out to be right did they
apologize i don't think so
and turn our entire country into one
giant sanctuary for criminal aliens
setting loose tens of thousands of
dangerous offenders and putting
ms-13 gang members straight into your
children's schools
and you know we've removed thousands and
thousands of
ms-13 gang members and i want to thank
ice
and i want to thank border patrol i want
to thank our great law enforcement
incredible people they're incredible
and the people that understand those
values are kelly
and david they understand those values
and you're with our law enforcement
right
100 i don't have to ask you that
they'll allow heroin cocaine fentanyl
and other deadly drugs to flood across
our borders again
and poison our youth they'll take away
your health care
they'll eliminate private insurance we
have 180 million people that love their
private insurers you can forget about
it and you'll lose your doctor remember
president obama said
you can keep your doctor you can keep
your plan guess what he said it 28 times
that was a lie that was a lot that
turned out to be a big great scam lie
and remember i got rid of the individual
mandate the most unpopular thing in
obamacare
fighting a lot of different fronts which
really doesn't make it obamacare anymore
by the way
they'll resume the war on christians and
attack catholic organizations like
little sisters of the poor
they will ban voter id we want voter id
is that so much to add
an institute universal
unsolicited maryland balloting in every
state
they will never be i'll tell you this
if we don't do something fast there will
never be another fair election
in america you know we're known for
elections and now we're
being left out all over the world about
this last election
and you've got to swarm it tomorrow now
the good thing about tomorrow it's one
state so you have a lot of eyeballs
watching it's tougher
than when you have 50 states and they do
it to
various various states i'd never say
anything like
you know i was leading in pennsylvania
by
hundreds of thousands of folks all of a
sudden i was tired i said what happened
they'll make washington dc and other
liberal places
the 51st 52nd 53rd states of the union
guaranteeing
the radical left a permanent majority of
the u.s senate
the house and the electoral college it
will make it really a
one party country and the party will be
the wrong party
they will pack the supreme court with
crazed extremists
and i'm not happy with the supreme court
they are not stepping up to the plate
they're not stepping up
how about that we don't have
look at the supreme court president of
the united states
i want to file suit i want to do and
they said sir you can't you really can't
do that why
so they have legal reasons complex legal
reasons it's wrong
if you're the president of the united
states and you get defrauded out of an
election
you should be able to file a suit but we
can't do that
they say sir you don't have standing how
about that
i'm the president seven
states you know i was winning by a lot
and then all of a sudden i was losing by
a little tiny bit just a little they
could only go so far
they had no idea we were going to do the
kind of numbers so that printing press
was really important
and they say i don't have standing to
bring a suit
what kind of a legal system is that but
the supreme court has let us down
so far who knows maybe they'll come back
maybe they'll come back they'll pack the
supreme court with crazed extremists
then they'll be saying you know i should
have
done something about this when they
start having 24
25 26 justices and they want to have the
justices rotate to the lowest courts
so they'll rotate these nine justices
will have a great time rotating
but they're bent on destroying our
constitution and overthrowing
america's founding if the left wins
these
senate seats they will abolish the
senate you know this
the filibuster they will knock it out
all i've been saying
to be honest with you for a long time
they're going to do that at some point
they're going to do that
and why don't we do it first i said it
if they're going to do it you might as
well do it first and now everybody said
you were right
but you know what i want to be wrong
because i want these two to win because
if they win
we don't want to do it it's a bad thing
for our country
but that would give them the power to
ram through every deluded piece of
left-wing legislation
that they've ever wanted that they've
ever dreamt of
your religious liberty will be gone your
second amendment will be gone
your borders and great new wall will be
gone
your police departments will be gone as
we know them and your life savings will
be gone
will be like a large-scale version of so
many other countries that you look at
that are poverty america as you know
it will be over and it will never i
believe
be able to come back again it'll be too
far gone
your vote tomorrow could lose and it
could be
your last chance to save the america
that we love
that's why i'm here i don't want to do
rallies for other people i told you
i'm here because of that because of
david and kelly the far left
wants to destroy our country demolish
our history
and erase everything that we hold dear
this could be the most important vote
you will ever cast
for the rest of your life it really
could be this is
so important i mean think of it it's so
important it's amazing actually that
in one state you have two races
simultaneously i don't think a thing
like that's ever happened before
if you don't show up the radical
democrats well when a lot of people say
oh well trump maybe he wants it that way
no
you know what i want i want a great
country i want these two very special
people to be elected
and i want to be clear you know if those
of you that
know how badly screwed we got i want to
be clear
that we can't let that happen again we
can't let that happen
again we're going to come back and i
really believe we're going to take
what they did to us on november 3rd
we're going to take it back
but these two people they they can't go
through this
they can't go through it
if you don't go and vote the socialist
of marxists
will be in charge of our country if you
don't fight to save your country with
everything you have
you're not going to have a country left
i love this state this state's been very
good to me we've had a lot of victories
in this state just had one on november
3rd actually
and i love the people of this state we
can't let that
happen the damage they do will be
permanent and will be irreversible
can't let it happen nothing and no one
will be able to stop them
these senate seats are truly the last
line of defense now i must preface that
by saying because they'll say he just
conceded
no no i don't think so
so kelly if i might add
i think we're going to win in which case
will be the last line of defense it's
called vino
vito vito vito
so tomorrow you must get out and vote
for david perdue and kelly lefler
over the last four years david perdue
has been one of our greatest allies and
strongest offenders in washington he's a
great gentleman david was a critical
vote and the right to pass
the largest package of tax cuts and
reforms in american history we did that
together we got it done
launching an incredible economic boom
the greatest tax cuts in the history of
our country think of it and the greatest
restrictions we were so restricted we
couldn't breathe in this country that's
one of the big i think it might have
been more important in many ways
than the tax cuts you would know that
being one of the great businessmen of
our world right
i think it was maybe more important when
georgia needed
a strong voice in washington after
hurricane michael
remember hurricane michael and i was
down here with david
but david perdue led the charge to get
the workers and farmers of your state
the relief you deserved he said sir can
we get a billion dollars
and i said we're gonna get it david we
got it very fast and there was no
mechanism to get it
you got hit with a hurricane the like
you have never seen before
came in from a location that is just
very unique it was a horrible thing i
was here for a long time with david and
he worked and he
and his uh his kin you know his kin the
great sunny purdue our
department of agriculture our secretary
of agriculture was fantastic also
but we worked very hard and we got the
farmers and the businesses the money
that they
had to have and now they're thriving
david has also been one of the most
courageous advocates fighting for an
immigration system that defends american
workers american wages
american families and american jobs he
led
the effort in congress to build a wall
that's right
and kelly helped on that she's a little
bit newer
to the senate but she helped a lot those
last moments you were there without you
it wouldn't have happened actually
crack down on deadly sanctuary cities
and chain migration
and institute on parallel protection for
our great citizens
he fought to help us replace nafta
disaster
with the brand new usmca they said it
couldn't be done a giant victory for
georgia
for workers and for farmers all over our
country
nafta was the worst trade deal probably
ever signed
and that maybe has to exclude some of
the crazy deals and
things they did with china he voted to
confirm
nearly 300 federal judges we have a
record on federal judges
and three supreme court justices which
is a tremendous thing
we have almost 300 federal judges
committed to interpreting our
constitution
as written no one fights harder for the
people
of georgia than david perdue david's
opponent
john ossoff is an unhinged radical
leftist he's not a senator
he's not a senator that's that's not a
center
also said that he's very proud to be
endorsed by
socialist crazy bernie sanders he's weak
on china
he promoted chinese propaganda and then
he failed to disclose his business ties
to the chinese county in his party
other than that he's a wonderful guy
right asof supports the largest tax hike
in american history if they get in
warnock
and also if they get in you're gonna
have the largest tax increase
that you've ever had it'll be the
largest tax increase in the history of
our country
for what the green new deal let's rip
down a building because its windows are
too big
let's build a building with no windows
among many other things he supports
the insane green new deal which would
crush middle class
parents trying to raise a family he will
support
the socialist takeover of american
health care
which will lead to rationing poverty and
death
assaf also backed the radical left-wing
crusade to defund police
the last summer he proudly joined the
anti-police mob he didn't like the
police he doesn't like our police
we love our police
[Applause]
[Music]
slandering our brave men and women in
blue
if you vote for john ossoff he will
attack our heroes he will destroy
our economy and he will betray you and
your family and it'll happen very
quickly
that's why you must vote and really
importantly get out tomorrow vote for
david perdue he's a great gentleman he
loves you
georgia has another fantastic champion
in senator kelly lefler kelly is a
staunch defender of our
incredible military i'm so proud of our
military she supports the wall
and she always stands with the heroes of
law enforcement
ice and border patrol i hated it kelly
when we got ballots in from the military
with trump all over it
and they got thrown into a river you saw
that
they threw ballots into a river from the
military with my name all over we want
trump
boom goes into the river that was just
one of many instances of problem
kelly is also a committed protector of
your second amendment rights
with kelly's vote we confirmed our third
new supreme court justice amy coney
barrett
[Applause]
working with david kelly helped rescue
the u.s economy from the china virus
passing nearly four trillion dollars in
economic relief saving over 1.5
million georgia jobs and rescuing
countless small businesses all across
your state
businesses that now are doing really
well and you know we also
came up with a vaccine nobody else would
have done that they would have done that
in 10 years
kelly and david also both strongly
support my efforts to provide
two thousand dollar stimulus checks to
hardworking americans across georgia
and across the nation and my reasoning
is simple i mean we're
conservative with money but my reasoning
is simple
you didn't cause this problem this
problem was caused by
china kelly is running against a hard
left extremist named
raphael warlock
warnick is the most radical and
dangerous left-wing candidate
ever to seek this office and certainly
in the state of georgia and he does not
have your values warnick is
publicly declared his support for
socialism
and he once welcomed the anti-american
communist dictator fidel castro to his
church he wanted him here
he liked castro i thought castro was a
nice guy
warner said that quote nobody can serve
both god
and the military a vicious smear against
thousands of patriotic service members
across the state of georgia he wants to
abolish cash bail you see how that's
working in new york city right not
working too well
he has called for quote opening up the
jails
and he slandered our police officers as
gangsters thugs and bullies
the choice for the voters of georgia
could not be more clear
john osoph on rap and rafael warlock
our fringe extremists who would wreck
everything georgia patriots
hold dear to their hearts kelly lefler
david perdue share your values and you
know that
they share your values like nobody
shares your values
i can tell you they share your values
they want to defend your interests and
they will always put
america first did you see the other day
what a great name america first
they announced they don't want to do the
america first policy how crazy
even if you're not going to do it which
is basically protect us we come first
right
but even and that includes financially
in every other way
even if you don't believe it you don't
say we're going to end america first
they want to end america first kelly i'd
love you to just come up and say a few
words would that be okay
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello georgia
thank you georgia i have an announcement
georgia
on january 6th i will object to the
electoral
college vote that's right
that's right thank you we're gonna get
this done
all right georgia but i have a very
important question for you
are you ready to show america that
george is a red
state
that's right that's right look this
president
fought for us we're fighting for him he
put
america first he put the american worker
first
thank you mr president he stood with our
men and women of law enforcement he
restored our military
my opponent radical liberal rafael
warnock he attacked yeah he attacked our
police
our military he spoke out against
israel evangelicals small businesses
georgia we have to hold the line you
have to get out and vote tomorrow
georgia we are the firewall to socialism
we have to get it done i love you guys
thank you god bless you
god bless georgetown
thank you kelly that was nice i'm glad i
invited her up
kelly i'm glad i invited you up that was
great thank you
that was so great
[Applause]
thank you thank you you know it really
is it's
fight for our country it's really fight
for our country not fight for trump it's
fight for our country because that's
what we're filing
also joining us tonight are georgia
representatives
marjorie taylor green i love volunteers
[Music]
come up here kelly wants you to come up
here come here
don't mess with her don't mess with her
[Music]
hello northwest georgia
all right let me tell you something i am
so fired up to hear
senator kelly lefler she's going to
object on
january 6th yeah
this is this is why i believe in her you
see when you have a strong senator
kelly lefler from georgia fighting for
you
and fighting for your president and
protecting your vote
this is why you have to turn out
tomorrow
right yes
we have to save our senate set senate
seats we have to save
america and stop socialism this is the
last line
we aren't going to hand over our senate
seats to a pastor
who preaches abortion from the pulpit
no he's he's preaching
murder of god's creation in the womb
holding a bible in his hand
if anything go out there and vote for
the unborn
tomorrow
right we've had enough
we're not going to let georgia go to two
radical
socialists no
i need you all to go out there and vote
our district
has to show up we've got to stop this
attack
stop our senate seats for being handed
over to these radicals
and we're going to fight for president
trump on january 6.
[Applause]
god bless georgia god bless america
let's do this
i also want to introduce to great
warriors friends of mine
andrew clyde and jody heist jody thank
you
thank you andrew thank you very much
great job
we have another friend of our south
carolina senator
lindsey graham
[Music]
[Applause]
and mike lee is here too but i'm a
little angry at him today
where's mike lee a little angry at you
today but that stuff
state representative vernon jones what a
great guy he is
a great man
and an early supporter of mine who's
also on
the ballot tomorrow public service
commissioner bubba
mcdonald
good you're going to do great
[Music]
great guy thank you bubba thank you good
luck tomorrow
you'll do well georgia republican party
chairman
david shaffer he's fighting he's out
there he is fighting
he is fighting by the way i also want to
say hello to
kelly's husband is one of the great
entrepreneurs in our country
he's respected by everybody he's a tough
guy but he is a sweetheart and he loves
your state i just want to say hello you
might
okay he doesn't want that he doesn't
want it but i will tell you he's
respected as a businessman respected by
everybody
and gives tremendous amounts of money to
charity and everything else thank you
very much
also a friend of mine and you know i
don't know what it is i'm not so good
with the bikes
you know i sort of say maybe i stay away
from a little bit
but chris cox is bikers for trump and
he's the founder
and he had more people show up for me
whenever i saw i'd go to
places i'd have two three four thousand
bikes
and secret service would go crazy i say
no
i'm so happy and they wouldn't do it for
any other reason they just wanted to
protect
the future president this was before i
won they were with me for whatever
reason bikers like me
and i like them chris cox wherever you
are chris
where's chris right i don't know why the
bikers like me chris but they do but i
like you guys a lot
and you're great we'd go to speeches and
we'd be packed
and we couldn't even get them they
didn't even want to be inside they'd
stood outside and they were protecting
their president when i became president
i never felt safer in my life thank you
that's true another man who's uh
respected by
everybody friend of mine david mcintosh
club for growth david david
thank you david respected by everybody
and i want to thank don jr did he do a
good job tonight i watched
playstore don is good
he sort of has they love our don
but he's uh he's working hard and i want
to thank don and kimberly
guilfoyle who has been incredible
and i also uh came with somebody who
people like a lot
people like her a lot i don't know she
doesn't really like the concept of
running for office she says what do i
need it for
dad ivanka where is ivanka
should we get ivanka up yes right
come on up here
[Music]
hello georgia
[Applause]
it is so incredible to be back here with
so many amazing hard-working georgia
families who are fighting
for our children's future each one of
you
[Music]
and it's so great to be back in georgia
with this warrior my father
the people's president
[Applause]
he is a tireless a tireless
champion for all of you and he will
never stop fighting and
by his side are two amazing
senators that we have to send back
to the senate and send a resounding
message that patriotism
is alive and well in georgia
[Music]
and georgia is going to keep freedom
alive in america please vote
thank you god bless you god bless
georgia
and god bless america and god bless
our president
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you ivanka thanks don kimberly
everybody thank you all
tomorrow our entire nation is counting
on the people of georgia
in a way the world is counting on the
people of georgia the fate of our
country is at stake it's in your hands
you must deliver a republican victory so
big that the democrats
can't steal it or cheat it away
we have all they'll be trying though
i'll tell you that
we have all seen what our opponents are
capable of doing
i ran two elections i won both of them
second one much more successful than the
first
but we can't let this happen any longer
on election night
we were leading by so much we're not
going to have that tomorrow we're not
going to have that tomorrow night where
you're leading and then all of a sudden
boom it's gone like magic
we won florida and ohio in record
numbers
we want iowa by 8.2
nobody's ever won those three states and
lost
never happened before it's almost
impossible unless
people do a lot of either get very lucky
or they cheat
we're up 293 000 votes
in michigan 112 000 votes in washington
in wisconsin we were way up 356 000
votes in georgia
356 000
and 700 000 votes in pennsylvania
it was over i should have run up to the
podium and said thank you very much for
this wonderful victory
then maybe they wouldn't have had time
to close those
booths right the counting rooms and do
what they did
but then it all started to disappear and
i tell the story because we can't let
this happen tomorrow
kelly so keep your eyes open
since the election we have put forth
indisputable evidence documenting
the rampant fraud which will be
announced on wednesday as you know
and i want to thank senator josh hawley
and ted cruz
and all of the incredible senators that
have stepped up to fight because they've
seen what happens they know it's a fraud
and not just here you know i watched
some of the people on fox i had no
choice i had no choice i had to
[Music]
i didn't have enough channels and they
said why is he fighting for georgia
it's not enough no i need three i'm
fighting in
eight actually but six and we're going
to win them all
but they said they said why one of the
people
a very fine woman actually but she said
why is he
fighting georgia it doesn't get him
there i said no but georgia
and pennsylvania and one other get me
there
and we have six and maybe eight if you
look at them
and we were leading all of them by a lot
until like a miracle it started to
quickly disappear
right here in georgia there were tens of
thousands of illegal votes cast
and counted you know that and here are
just a few
examples watch this for tomorrow
we're up 10 315 ballots were cast by
individuals
whose name and date of birth matches a
georgia resident
who died in 2020 prior to the
election then your wacky secretary of
state said two people
two people now i don't know how many
people are on that list
but it's a lot of people 2 500
ballots were cast by individuals whose
name in date of birth
matches an incarcerated felon
in a georgia prison maybe they aren't
all there but
they did a lot of work i paid a lot of
money to a lot of people i can tell you
that
4502 illegal ballots
were cast by individuals who do not
appear
on the state's voter rolls well that's
sort of strange
18 325 illegal ballots were cast
by individuals who registered to vote
using an address listed as vacant
according to the postal service at least
86
880 ballots were cast by people whose
registrations were illegally backdated
oh i can't believe that happened
66 000 votes you'd have to understand
we're down by a little more than 11
000. so every one of these is
determinative 66 000
votes in georgia were cast by people
under the legal
voting age at least 15 000 ballots were
cast by individuals who moved out of the
state
prior to the november third election and
maybe they moved back in i don't know i
mean i can't tell
moved out let's go back usually it takes
a little time right you know
we moved out let's go back darling
george's absency ballot rejection rate
went from an average of three percent
in 2016 and
then went down very low to almost
zero now oh think of it almost zero
if you multiply that out and this is
with
many many more ballots boring and went
to almost zero
48 out of 159 counties in georgia
rejected
no ballots at all
these absentee ballot rejection rates
prove that the tens of thousands of
illegitimate ballots were counted
there were more absentee ballots in 2020
than ever before before but magically
far fewer ballots were rejected
this alone is more than enough to swing
the election to us
this one thing i'm going over individual
in all of the swing states
now they'll check this out and that's
fine and you take a look at it officials
egregiously violated state laws in order
to solicit
facilitate and promote cheating and
theft on a scale
never seen before these crooked and
incompetent officials suspended
signature verification i said i want you
to go to fulton county to check
the signatures because hundreds of
thousands of ballots came in
i want you to check the signature to see
if it compares to somebody that lived
there two years
four years or six years ago they don't
want to do it the secretary of state
and your incompetent governor although
he thinks i've been a great president
they illegally flooded their states with
absentee ballots
and they deployed hundreds of illicit
ballot drop boxes in corrupt
democrat-run cities among many other
flagrant violations of law they put
these drop boxes there
and in a number of cases they'd be gone
for three days to take them up and they
where are they where are they they were
gone georgia's secretary of state agreed
to
a litigation settlement which is
something that nobody's ever seen one
like this i
i want to just tell you that stacey
abrams took him to the cleaners
that drastically and illegally changed
the state's election procedures
they never got the mandated approval
from your state legislature
who by the way you have some great
people in your
legislature some great great people who
agree with what we're saying and even
more so
but think of it they never got the
approval you have to by law
under the constitution you can't just do
these deals and not get the approval
and your secretary of state or whoever
it was
made this horrible consent decree
horrible
which got rid of so much safety it's a
disgraceful thing
and it was only approved by your local
politicians
him and local judges you can't do that
you have to have your state
legislatures do it that's true with all
states tens of
thousands of votes are missing we go all
over the world telling people how to run
their elections and we don't even know
how to run ours the most unhappy person
right now anywhere in the united states
is hillary clinton
because she's asking the democratic
party
why the hell did you do this for me
why didn't you do it for me
why the hell didn't you notice how quiet
she's been i shouldn't have said that
now tonight jill
but you notice how quiet she's furious
because she said don't forget i won
michigan
by 10 000 votes we did much better as i
said this time
much much better but i won michigan from
her by 10 000 votes i won wisconsin by a
small you know
i mean they could have done that one and
not get caught
we caught him we caught him
and i say to people like mike lee that
are here and lindsay
i say if they got
approved and verified they use the word
verified
votes that are fraudulent and then we
find out after because you can't do it
that quickly it doesn't go that quickly
it's a lot of work and a lot of votes
and a lot of people
and then we find out that they were
frauds
like in one state where you had let's
say you lost by
25 000 votes they verify it and that's
supposed to be the end
but shortly thereafter we find out that
we actually won the state by 250
000 votes does that mean that that state
plus
others adds up to being your president i
don't think it should
i don't think it should i don't think
that kelly feels it [ __ ] i don't think
that
marjorie feels it should in wisconsin
over 90 000 ballots were illegally
harvested
can't do that not allowed to through
so-called human
drop boxes and over 500 illegal
unmanned drop boxes were put out
statewide
in addition over 170 000 absentee votes
were counted that are blatantly illegal
under wisconsin law
and should never have been included in
the talent by the way i lost them
it was razor thin there's 170 000 votes
the margin in wisconsin is only 20 000
votes so
this issue alone would have won that
state for us many times over
we were leading at 10 o'clock in the
evening by a lot
in pennsylvania there were 205
000 more ballots cast than there were
voters how do you get around that one
which remains completely unexplained you
have great
senators and representatives there and
nobody can explain it
but think of that and in other places
too you had more
ballots than you had voters you had more
votes think of it than you had
voters by a lot in addition democrats
state supreme court judges and democrat
secretary of state effectively abolished
the signature verification process
right here they counted ballots cast
after deadlines and they allowed ballots
to be illegally fixed
in democrat controlled areas
and i i say this because you can't let
this happen tomorrow and i hope
all the politicians are listening
there's an unexplained 400
000 vote discrepancy between the number
of mail-in ballots in pennsylvania sent
out
reported on november 2nd 2020
and the number reported on november 4th
they can't explain it
400 000 previously unreported mail-in
ballots
magically appeared they couldn't explain
it
and all of a sudden they just happened
to find 400 000
that's a lot of people amazing
[Music]
and the pennsylvania legislature is not
happy
pennsylvania also had an estimated eight
thousand dead voters fifty five thousand
ballots received back before they were
even sent how about that
the ballots were received but they
weren't sent yet oh uh
get them out fast please many more with
no mail date
and 14 000 ballots illegally cast by
out-of-state voters
those are numbers and those are numbers
we got from them so they can't say oh
the numbers aren't so good
in clark county nevada over 130
000 ballots this is far just so you know
all these numbers these are far more
than
we need were processed on machines
where the signature matching threshold
was intentionally lowered to a level
that you could sign your name santa
claus
and it wouldn't pick it up didn't pick
up anything
more than 42 000 people in nevada
double voted that's more than we needed
by far
in arizona more than 36 000 votes were
cast by non-citizens
and there were 11 000 more ballots than
there were voters
seems to be a trait doesn't it this was
like
at the super bowl where you have 15
cameras and they say camera number four
you're on camera number three you're on
in michigan according to one analyst
over 35 000 ballots listed no address
over 13 ballots were cast by
non-residents
and an estimated 17 000 ballots were
cast by dead people
some dead people by the way also
requested
an application that's true those are the
ones that really bother me
they not only vote but they request an
application that's a double
in addition there is the highly
troubling matter of dominion voting
machines
and i want you to watch this very
carefully tomorrow everybody you have to
watch it carefully i want to read you
from a letter from georgia state senator
william
legon you know who he is right highly
respected guy
do you mr president is chairman of the
georgia senate judiciary committee on
elections
i request that you immediately send an
outside team of cyber experts to
investigate
potential hacking and other
irregularities associated with
dominion voting systems scanners
ballot marking devices ballots polling
pads
used in the 2020 general election in
georgia
you don't hear this from your secretary
of state and you don't hear this from
your governor
and you do have a great legislature i
have to tell you but the governor won't
let him hold the session to decertify
on december 30th 2020 the committee held
a hearing investigating
potential fraud and other irregularities
during georgia's 2020 general election
the committee first unanimously approved
a report
dated december 17 2020 discussing a
myriad of voting irregularities and
potential fraud
in georgia 2020 general election
discussed in an earlier hearing held on
december 3rd
notably the committee stated in the
executive summary that the november 3rd
2020 general election
was chaotic and reported results must be
viewed
as untrustworthy they are untrustworthy
despite the line of crap that you hear
from these people that represent you
i don't know where they come from the
committee then heard
and this is from one of your most highly
respected political representatives
the committee then heard additional
testimony concerning
voting irregularities during the 2020
general election
including testimony and a real-time test
demonstrating serious irregularities
with dominions voting machines
three events discussed at this hearing
stand out and require a forensic order
of the dominion
voting machines in georgia to be
immediately conducted
the governor will not let us do it we've
been asking him now
since november 4th the day after the
election
he won't let us do it why won't he let
us do it
there's only one reason i can think
first the dominion voting machines
employed in fulton county
that's the home of stacy had an
astounding
93.67 error rate 93.67 error rate
in the scanning of ballots requiring a
review panel to adjudicate or
determine the voters intent so they're
going to a voter intent
what did the voter mean by this vote
somebody votes for trump
you know i think that voter meant
something other he doesn't want trump
let's just switch it around
think of that they're trying to
determine the voter's intent
in over 106 000 ballots out of a total
of
113 000 ballots
this is from your representative highly
respected
the national average for such an error
rate is far
less than 1.2 so that was 93
the source of this astronomical error
rate must be identified to determine if
these machines were set up
or designated to allow for a third party
to disregard the actual ballot cast by
the registered voter this is what i have
there was no way look at this crowd we
have here biden
came here he had
[Applause]
gallup gallup you know the gallup poll
they did i don't i don't say this
braggingly
the most admired man in the world or the
country
i don't say it i say it for a different
reason
so i came in first obama came in second
and biden came in way low
then i say and they say and people have
said
how is it possible that a guy who got 80
million votes
can't get any votes for the most admired
man you know why
because he didn't come in first that's
why
second again from this
very respected political leader second
there is clear evidence that tens of
thousands of votes were switched
from president trump to former vice
president biden
in several counties throughout georgia
for example in bib county anybody live
in bib county
bibb president trump was reported to
have
29 391 votes
at 9 11 p.m
while simultaneously former vice
president joe biden was reported to have
thousand two eighteen minutes later at
the next update these vote
numbers switched with president trump
now having 17
000 and biden now having 29
391.
that was a switch of over 12 000 votes
it was like a miracle third during this
hearing
a presenter demonstrated that a dominion
poll
could be hacked into in real time
because it was connected to the internet
now anything connected to the internet
that's not good
but this demonstration proved that these
machines could allow votes to be
siphoned off
or added during the voting process
because they're
connected to the internet cyber security
experts agree that voting machines
should not be connected to the internet
at any
time in any way shape or form
did you see that during the hearing this
guy's sitting there
well can you connect into the machine
jess
how do you do that within about 25
seconds
he controlled the internet former vice
president biden
led georgia by only 11
779 votes every one of the things i told
you about almost is more votes than what
we're talking about
the crime that was committed in this
state is
immeasurable an immediate forensic audit
of an appropriate sampling of dominions
voting machines
and related equipment is critical to
determine the level of illegal
fraudulent ballots
improperly counted in georgia during the
2020 general election
and during tomorrow's race you've got to
be very careful
and let me also quickly read a letter
from mark fincham
chairman of the arizona house a very
respected man
federal relations committee dear mr
president
subsequent to the election members of
the legislature were inundated with
complaints
from constituents relating to the
intensity of the general election
and the integrity more important than
anything else
and the accuracy of canvassed results
in many instances constituents reported
that their
earlier in-person ballots may not have
been correctly processed or tabulated in
myacopa county officials members of the
legislature have conducted two public
hearings in recent weeks
during which significant evidence of
fraudulent and illegal voting in arizona
has been demonstrated
through expert and eyewitness testimony
for example in pima county
and miacopa county it appears that 143
000 illegal votes were actually injected
into the ballot system think of that
no but think of this also you know the
press won't report this they're probably
turning off oh we don't like this
they don't like this they don't want to
talk about numbers they talked about my
phone call they don't like my phone call
everyone love my phone call they don't
like talking about numbers
because nobody knew the numbers were so
egregious
also an expert mathematician concluded
that the only explanation for the actual
voting results in arizona
is that 100 think of this
130 percent of democrats voted for
candidate biden
and a negative 30 percent voted for
president trump
now think of that in order to get to the
numbers
130 percent of the voters
that's a little tough to get okay
had a vote for him and minus 30 had a
vote for me
and that gets you to a hundred percent
and nobody has a 100
voting for all of these people who think
it's too late
does that mean that we're forced to
approve a fraudulent election or an
election
with massive irregularities i don't
think so
i don't think so i want to thank those
two
great political leaders but we have many
other letters just like
that same thing hundreds of thousands of
votes are missing
the only way to combat the democrat
fraud is to flood your polling places
with a historic tidal wave of republican
voters tomorrow
[Music]
[Applause]
because at a certain point the machines
are going to explode
they almost did with me unfortunately
they didn't quite get there but
we'll figure that out and i just want
mike lee to listen to this when i'm
talking because you know what
we need his vote this election is your
chance to stand up
to the corrupt democrat machine and show
them that the american people
are still in charge
with your help over the last four years
we built the greatest political movement
in the history of our country
there's never been anything like this
kelly when did i
say well do this like two days ago three
days ago right
and look at this and we love you all for
being here we really do i'm glad the
weather's here
we love you all but there's never been a
movement like this you know i say it all
the time
and the politicians the lame stream
media as i call them affectionately
if that weren't true they'd say that's
wrong there's never been a movement like
this
i mean you have people that won one
state
and they become world famous for the
rest of their lives you have people that
came in
second in new hampshire and their world
we won
everything and we want it now a second
time
hate to bore you with that expression
but we want it now a second time
and i don't want to win it a third time
i really want to win it the second time
it's harder
somebody came up to me today kelly and
they said
sir you're way up in four years
nobody can come close to me i said i'm
not interested in four years i'm
interested in like eight weeks ago
four years four years is a long time
it's actually two and two you know we'll
take back the house for kevin
and marjorie jody we'll bring back the
house
right we'll bring back the house
no if we didn't win i'd be all upset of
course if i didn't win you probably
wouldn't want me you know what i'll fail
big difference between losing and
winning and having it stolen
no but they talk about four years sir
you haven't made nobody can come closer
and i say
no we're gonna we go this way first and
i think we're gonna do it i really
believe
because there's no way we could have won
every single state
and for fox not one state this is one of
many
we win every state and they're going to
have this guy be president
and he can't speak he can't talk already
we've achieved more than anyone
thought possible and we are just getting
started
and and honestly it's you it's amazing
what happened i don't even know why the
hell i say let's have a rally we have a
rally in thousands and thousands
honestly there's never been a go out on
the extreme
there's never been anything like this in
the history of our country
and the election is over the
presidential election
and we have a big one tomorrow but
there's never been anything like this
in the history of our country our
economy is coming back
it's roaring back our stock market is an
all-time high who would have thought
that
we're rounding the term because of the
turn because of what we did with
the vaccines and nobody else would have
done it it would have taken so long the
economy boomed
at 33.4 last quarter that's
the fastest rate ever recorded
and we're talking about pandemic
during a pandemic we've already slashed
the unemployment rate in half
and for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars rebuilding
foreign nations fighting foreign wars
and defending foreign borders you know
we're bringing many of our great troops
home i mean i hate to say but
gotta do it we've been in afghanistan
for 19 years i think that's enough
i think that's enough we've got a lot of
uh very few left
and uh very proud nothing worse than
going to dover
and meeting the parents of our great
warriors that have
fallen our great warriors coming home
so badly wounded or dead and
on countries that many of you have never
even heard about
so we bring our soldiers home we've been
incredible warriors
we can beat anybody nobody has our
equipment nobody has
our military nobody has our people but
we
aren't over there to be policemen we're
not over there to be
policing the warriors the fighters
and that's what we want them for that's
what we have to have them for
but we brought a lot of them home we are
finally protecting our nation rebuilding
our cities
and we're bringing our jobs our
factories and our troops
back to the usa where they belong
[Applause]
but everything that we've achieved
together is on the line tomorrow
our fight to take back our country from
the big donors the big media
and the horrendous big tech giants that
our politicians not these two
politicians
are afraid to attack section 230 we have
to get rid of section 230 politicians
well you're not going to have a country
very long taking away all your rights if
you
want to send a message to the powerful
forces that
are trying to control your country
you must get out and vote tomorrow for
david perdue and kelly lefler
[Applause]
with your help we're going to continue
our mission
to save america and we're going to
continue
our mission of america first
it's very simple each of us here tonight
is united by the same core vision
and the same timeless american values we
love our country
together we believe that faith and
family not government and bureaucracy
are the center of american life
we will defend the right to life
religious liberty
free speech and the right to keep and
bear arms which i want to take away from
you
and we will always support the heroes of
law enforcement
we will maintain america's unrivaled
military might
and we will preserve peace through
strength you know when i first
got elected and before i got elected in
2015
and 2016 before they were in debates and
everyone said oh he's going to cause
wars he's going to cause wars i think
i'm the only president
in many many decades that didn't get
into a war right
[Applause]
remember north korea was going to be a
tremendous nuclear fight and all this
what happened with that i got along very
well with kim jong-un
i don't think that joe's going to based
on what i've heard but
but i got along very well with him and
you know people
say whatever happened with north korea
we got along well
but you know they all said that with my
personality i'll be in a big war very
soon within the first two weeks right
what happened what happened and they
don't want to mess with us either
that i can tell you david and kelly will
protect social security and medicare
and they will always protect patients
with pre-existing conditions
we will stop the radical indoctrination
of our students and restore
patriotic education to our school
we will teach our children to love our
country
honor our history and always respect
our great american flag
and we will live by the words of our
national motto
in god we trust and it'll stay that way
from atlanta to augusta to savannah to
columbus
from athens and i want to say hello to
herschel walker athens
[Applause]
10.2 yards to carry for a while
he made a lot of quarterbacks look very
good we love herschel
to right here in dalton georgia we
inherit the legacy of generations of
american patriots
who gave their blood sweat and tears to
defend our country and
to defend our freedom we stand on the
shoulders of american heroes who cross
the oceans
settle the continent tame the wilderness
laid down the railroads
raised up the great skyscrapers and won
two world wars
defeated fascism and communism and made
america into the single
greatest nation in the history of the
world
and the best is yet to come
[Applause]
and proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country
our fight to drain the washington swamp
and reclaim
america's destiny and dignity has
only just begun we will not bend we will
not break
we will not yield we will never give in
we will never give up we will never back
down
we will never ever surrender
[Applause]
because we are americans and we are from
georgia and our hearts
bleed red white and blue
we are one movement one people one
family
and one glorious nation under god
and together with the incredible people
of georgia
we have made america powerful again our
military
we have made america wealthy again our
stock market
we have made america strong again look
at that arm
[Applause]
we have made america proud again we're
proud of our country
we have made america safe
again and we
will make america great again
go get em david go get em kelly
go get em
[Music]
thanks
[Music]
there's no need to feel down
[Music]
there's a place
[Music]
and i'm sure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all by himself
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
today
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i was watching your shoes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ] out
[Music]
wow
[Music]
oh
hey
[Music]
[Music]
ballerina
[Music]
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
and then tickets are gone
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
today
15
[Music]
pretty nice
i love
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you